[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
coming up then we'll see what's making
the headlines with the conservative
commentator tim montgomery
and the politics editor for the online
magazine galdem
moya lithium mclean they'll be with us
right through until midnight
to the front pages though first of all
the metro splashing with
up your game reportedly the prime
minister's message to
social media firms over how they police
racism on their
platforms according to the eye instagram
has said the use of the
monkey emoji and racially abusive
messages to england players
doesn't in and of itself constitute a
violation of its community standards
however it's important to point out the
company has not condoned the messages
themselves
the sun reports that the father of
england defender harry maguire
had his ribs broken in the disturbances
at wembley on sunday night the telegraph
speaks to a couple who claimed they were
barred
from boarding a flight when it emerged
they'd been given doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine
which was made in india while the star
takes a look at
personal responsibility around the
lifting of covered restrictions
there's anger among mps including boris
johnson's own back benches over the
government's 4 billion
pound reduction to the foreign aid
budget that's the lead for
the guardian the daily mail has word
that british soldiers will not be
prosecuted in relation to incidents
during the troubles
that is also the lead for the express
witch hunts have handed veterans to end
their headline
and the financial times has a story
concerning the u.s
consumer price index
so tim montgomery and moyer lithium
maclean are here welcome to both of you
great to see you
oh plenty to discuss different stories
has to be said all over the front pages
let's kick off with the metro the
fallout from
the racial abuse of certain england
players
the government's decision to meet up
with tech companies
up your game the headline tim for the
metro
was this just good diversion from the
government do you think facing its own
criticism after
failure their failure to call out or
some of them the uh taking of the knee
ahead of the uh the tournament
you're being so cynical anna to suggest
that
well i you know i think one of the
silliest expressions we've ever heard
in sort of our upbringing was that old
rhyme
you know sticks and stones may break my
bones but names will
will never hurt me we know that the
abuse that is directed
at any of us for whatever reason can
really
really sting and i i think you know the
the truth is and that the good truth is
that
most people's experience of racism
in sort of the real tangible world um
has generally been in decline
and we've seen some horrible examples
where it's very real
in the last couple of days not least
with the marcus marcus rashford
mural but where the abuse is sort of out
of control
is in social media much of it as gary
southgate has said is coming from abroad
but stum is still coming from the uk and
part of the problem i think with social
media is that anyone can set up an
account
on most of these platforms there's no
credit card or anything else involved so
that it's impossible or very difficult
to trace people if they've used a false
email address
and after they've said something perhaps
racist or an objectionable
in another way and i think it's long
past time
that the government really puts the
social media giants
onto the hot spot and ask them to
actually justify
how they are registering and people who
might be guilty
of them these horrible examples of
racist abuse we've seen online
yes and the eye i suppose digs into some
of the defense of these tech companies
um monkey emoji is okay to send to black
players says
instagram uh they they use algorithms we
know to try and weed all of this out
uh so many messages of course are sent
um where
um the point i suppose they're trying to
make is that i've not every time a
monkey emoji is used
uh it's meant in any racially pejorative
way
uh well i do think it's important to
point out that um
instagram itself has not individually
responded
to the monk emojis in fact it's the
automatic response which
goes to the heart of the problem um when
they said they didn't go against our
community guidelines that is an
automatic response people receive when
they report this racism
but that is the problem because they use
these algorithms because uh the
human moderators they have in place are
either too few or they're overwhelmed by
the amount of
content they're having to sift through
these things are not being caught the
context is not being captured
and what you get instead is things like
racism slips to the net whereas i think
we saw recently
in certain countries you'll have um pro
lgbt or
pro pro ethnic minority sentiments
instead get caught on social media
um and it's really interesting because
there's been a lot of research into
algorithms
and how algorithms can often reflect
sort of systematic racism in our
societies because
they're built by people just like you or
me and those biases get baked in
so what we have to look at here is the
use of algorithms and also the use of
moderators
and how can these companies improve them
i think it's very important to know that
instagram is owned by facebook
and facebook has also been plagued by
these problems yes and i suppose
somebody
who has their account cancelled could
just get a new email address and start
another one i mean it's
you know it's a never-ending problem in
some respects isn't it um but what about
the the politicians in all of this
um the finger pointed specifically at
pretty patella as we've heard in the
last two days
ross johnson before as well um the eye
telling us that the pm
is has avoided an awkward downing street
reception
for the squad following this round with
with pretty patel
um and going to the guardian uh steve
baker
has also been speaking out about this
hasn't he tim what has he said
yeah i think this is the second sort of
quite prominent conservative mp
who has um expressed concern at the
position that the conservative party the
conservative government's taken we had
johnny mercer
the former defense minister yesterday
and now we've had steve baker
who i think has been someone who like me
has worried about the connotations
of taking the knee um i hope none of you
know none of the people who've been
sort of spotlighted over the last couple
of days by
critics of the conservative party
support the kind of racism
that we have seen but some of us do
object to the black lives
matter movement and it's some of its
extreme views in the usa including
defunding the police
and opposing things like capitalism and
the nuclear family
but i think steve baker might be on to
something he's
saying that despite all the kind of
intellectual arguments that i've just
made and that people like him have just
made
the overall thing that people are
hearing from the conservative party
is that they oppose measures and uh
gestures
um acts that oppose racial justice
and if that is fundamentally where the
conservative party has got to in the
eyes of
young england players young britons
generally then that's obviously a bad
place for the conservative party
to be intellectually defensible position
but perhaps emotionally and politically
the conservative party has got to sort
of
um i've got to sort of re-um
calibrate what we're saying in order to
make it clear
to uh people anti-racism and people who
are guilty of racism
that there is no place for any kind of
hateful
attitude a bit of bigotry in british
society
so so i mean the point that pretty patel
had made that this was
gesture politics should she not be
saying stuff like that
because it gives the wrong impression or
or did she did she genuinely believe
that and
and and therefore said it i mean what's
the point where do you go from there
from what you said tim
well well i would say i supported what
um
pretty patel said i felt that the taking
the knee
uh gesture was so associated with the
black lives matter movement that has an
extreme political agenda
that it wasn't objectionable i did
object to it i do object to it
but you get to a point where people
begin to think that your opposition to
taking the knee
is because you oppose racial justice and
after a while you just have to give up
on
an intellectual argument and just oppose
and
just sort of surrender almost and i'm
afraid that's where we might have got to
on this point because the battle against
racism is far more important
than fighting some sort of um tactical
battle against the the black lives
matter movement although i'm
not quite willing to give up on that
fully yeah and i suppose gareth
southgate moyer
really did try to explain it right at
the start didn't he about put yourself
in
in the position of a young black player
and how they feel about that that's
where you need to be on this issue
and perhaps people like tim are
listening to that too
uh well yes exactly and i think it's
very interesting that tim has
in fact uh changed his mind because i
heard him on bbc politics live and
channel 4 earlier
in fact still saying that taking the
knee was representing this divisive sort
of politics
so that change of heart must have come
very quickly but i must say
i'm pleased to hear it because um the
only way to
oppose racism is be actively anti-racist
and the fact that even people like steve
baker
are recognizing that um being the
attitude to taking a knee
is becoming associated with active sort
of um
racist sentiment since being wildly
opposed by the majority of the public
um says to me that we're on our way to
recognizing what people have been trying
to say from the beginning that taking
the knee was a gesture to oppose racism
and if you're against suggested supposed
racism
i have to ask what are you standing for
yeah and some amazing scenes today
um in manchester at this marcus rashford
uh mural which is a double-page spread
in the daily mail
of people covering up graffiti with
supportive messages
i mean that's really genuinely
heartwarming isn't it after
what we've seen and what we've talked
about for the last couple of days tim
absolutely i think marcus rashford um is
he's not just um just behind me there's
a picture of old trafford i'm a
manchester united fan and i'm a marcus
rashford fan
as well but he's just a great human
being you know i may not agree with all
of his political emphasis but
his concern to feed children his concern
to
you know produce a more equitable
society you know is
he's just a good person he's a role
model for so many
young people and yeah he missed a really
bad penalty
his a is his attempt and the other night
was atrocious for a
you know a footballer but that hasn't
got anything to do with the nastiness
and bile that's been directed to him
in the last few days his statement in
response the support for his community
that's in a way what we should focus on
now the racists
shouldn't get the attention that they
deserve the people putting those
stickers
on that mural they are i think the true
representatives of the british people
and we should celebrate them rather than
focus on uh the nastiness of the racists
quick thought moyer uh yeah i think we
should focus on
the people and the british people who
have put those stickers up but i think
we also have to recognize
um who stokes racism in this country and
how
people at the top can exacerbate that
sentiment on the ground
and why we might be in a position where
more of mural of marcus rashford is
defaced
um and how can we start combating that
yeah
mural is a word i can't say actually
i know you have the same problem no idea
how you're supposed to pronounce that
but like
george christian nuclear i seem to
represent it uh well coming up
scotland's first minister and the mayor
of london uh break with boris johnson
uh in their guidance on mask we will
find out more in just a moment
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now tim montgomery and
lithian mclean welcome back to both of
you so masks are still a hot issue it
appears makes the front page of the
financial times moya nicholas sturgeon
and indeed the london mayor both wanting
to keep them
um yet we've heard defense again today
from the government for
moving forward your your thoughts on
this
uh yes while we had a defense i i think
it was much more muted defense than we
have in previous weeks uh
boris said that masks would be required
in most
indoor spaces even if they're not going
to legislate for them and i think
scotland's refusion of getting rid of
marcel together or putting it down to
personal responsibility
shows that there has been an
overwhelming shift um on the side of the
scientists who have been calling for
these masks
so i do i don't think masks going
anywhere is the short answer
yeah tim do you think the government had
wished they hadn't been so
free and easy with this um you know many
ministers come out and said i can't wait
to get rid of them
was that was that the wrong tone do you
think from uh from a few weeks ago
yes anna in a word i think it was
probably the wrong tone
overall i think the government direction
is right
um given the level of vaccination we
have in the uk
now the the time of year and if we can't
sort of liberate
people now and get things like the
entertainment sector you know back
up and running where many jobs and
livelihoods you know
upon which to depend upon but i also
think that
whereas you can excuse not having masts
in places like restaurants and
nightclubs
which people can choose to attend or not
attend lots of people need public
transport they have to go on public
transport for work to see family for
medical appointments
and so i think it's important actually
as the mayor of london and
first minister scotland are doing is to
continue to have mandatory mask wearing
in those setups
yeah let's move on to foreign aid sorry
to speed through
and win for the government but at the
cost of a number of former
conservative prime ministers coming out
and disagreeing with them moya
uh yeah so this is the unfortunately
they they forced a quick vote on uh
foreign aid cuts which initially had
been passed back in january
and they've stayed in place but it was
only there was some tory rebels i think
about 24
um because there's been serious
discontent with the cuts that are
happening which will be about 4 billion
and the impact this is going to have on
the poorest people around the world
particularly women who in
war in war zone areas sexual health
services those
aspects are going to be really hit hard
by as removing aid and
a lot of people in the government think
it just doesn't make sense okay moya tim
thank you both so much